COLEEN MURPHY: You
need to figure out
what makes you
excited and what's
going to make you come
into lab every day.
I always want to come
into lab, because I
want to bother them and ask
them what they found out
while I was gone.
That excites me.
My name is Coleen Murphy.
I'm a professor of genomics
and molecular biology
at Princeton University.
You doing [? germine ?]
stuff today?
[? SUBJECT 1: I'm ?] actually
doing that for [INAUDIBLE].
COLEEN MURPHY: The goal
of our research lab
is to try to understand what are
the molecular mechanisms that
underlie aging.
We use a small laboratory
animal called C. elegans.
So C. elegans is
this little worm.
It's not scary.
It's very tiny.
And the reason we use it
is because 80% of its genes
are shared with humans.
By working on a
problem like aging,
there's also the hope that
we can help other people
down the road.
SUBJECT 2: So I set up
the one, the first cross.
And I'll be doing the
second cross tomorrow.
COLEEN MURPHY: OK.
SUBJECT 2: And then I am
setting up the first cross--
COLEEN MURPHY: I like to work
on a bunch of different things
at once.
As anyone in the lab will tell
you, I like having-- we have,
you know-- we counted
the other day.
We have 20 ongoing projects.
And while that can
be a lot to juggle,
it really makes it interesting
to come into lab every day,
and talk to my students, and
find out some new, cool thing
that they've found.
So how's the analysis
going with the [INAUDIBLE]?
SUBJECT 3: I finished,
like, all of last week.
And then because I'm
putting together the slides,
Rachel said she would pick up.
RACHEL AREY: She is a great role
model for female scientists.
She kind of, in a way,
has it all, I guess.
She has a family, she's
successful, she's great,
and I just love working for her.
I can't say enough
positive things about her.
But she also really
fosters independence,
which is important
for what we do,
because my goal is to eventually
run my own laboratory.
And she really lets me
think outside the box,
pursue whatever project
I'm interested in,
and tells you to just
kind of run with it.
And she's not afraid
of new things either.
COLEEN MURPHY: It's
not a medical school.
And so what this means for me
is that I can work on something
that seems somewhat
esoteric that eventually
leads back to public health.
But you're not
being forced to do
something that has immediate,
really immediate practicality.
And that is great,
because we never
would've ended up studying
the things that we do study
if that had been the
demand from the beginning.
And so having that sort
of academic freedom
that you get at a
place like Princeton,
where it's not a medical
school, I actually
think is really helpful
for ending up doing
medical research, in fact.
And the students all come in
with various backgrounds, too.
And so at this point, because
they develop the assays
they use-- it's a
little embarrassing,
but they're the
experts in what we do.
I have the big picture
idea, but they're
the ones who know how to
do every single thing.
So when someone asks me how--
like, nit-picky questions,
I always say, well, you need
to ask Rachel that question,
because she knows
exactly how you do this.
So they're the experts,
really, at this point.
RACHEL AREY: --HG.
INDIA ROGERS-SHEPP: Because I
just chunked the [? AWC. ?] And
the plate I wrote
on it was for--
RACHEL AREY: That one's it.
[?
INDIA ROGERS SHEPP: My crown? ?]
RACHEL AREY: No,
it's right here.
INDIA ROGERS-SHEPP: I remember
reading that, you know,
there was someone
in Coleen's life
who really encouraged her to
take that next step further
to realize and fulfill
her self potential.
And I think that she's done
the same with me by inviting
me to work in her lab.
And I don't really
come from-- no one
in my family does anything
related to research.
And I feel like
she's kind of helped
me realize, like,
this is something
that I could really see
myself doing in future years.
It's something that
I've come to love.
RACHEL AREY: She
really, I think,
emphasizes work-life
balance a whole lot.
And she does not, like, keep
us on a timetable, time clock.
And she understands that you
need your time to do things.
We have plenty of lab
members with families.
And she totally
supports that and has
been nothing but supportive.
COLEEN MURPHY: One of the
surprising things, I guess,
about doing this job has
been how wonderful it
has been to be able to
have kids during this time.
So a lot of women, I
think, talk themselves
out of doing science
or becoming professors
when they are in graduate
school or doing their postdoc.
And in fact, actually,
it's a really flexible job.
And so it's been pretty
reasonable to try
to do all of that at once.
And so I just wanted
to convey-- because I
think women get a lot of
discouraging information.
And I would like to convey
to the graduate students
and postdocs it actually really
is a reasonable path to take.
And they should stay in science.
INDIA ROGERS-SHEPP: [LAUGHS]
RACHEL AREY: I just set it up.
INDIA ROGERS-SHEPP:
That's perfect.
All right.
COLEEN MURPHY: You know, being
excited about your question
is really the most
important thing.
And it's hard.
At the end of graduate
school, right, I always
tell the students, you
start in all excited,
and then things start working
about your fourth year,
and then you get tired
around your fifth year.
And that's normal, right?
I always tell them that.
But they shouldn't
get discouraged.
And almost always, they have
a ton of data at that point.
And you're almost, like, pushing
them out of the nest, right.
They should be sick
of you, because it's
time for them to go elsewhere.
It's part of the process.
I hope that they always
retain this idea that there's
something fun to
study and there's just
something exciting.
And that's what I mostly
want them to learn.